[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute werde ich eine dumpfe torte backen
und zwar ist meine freundin lisa gerade
schwanger und in ein paar wochen steht
schon der entbindungstermin bevor
und ja ich und noch ein paar andere
freundinnen wir haben hier eine baby
party gemacht also eine
überraschungsparty und zu einer
überraschungsparty gehört natürlich auch
eine überraschungs torte und elisa mag
elefanten swayze hat auch ihr
kinderzimmer also das zukünftige mit
einem elefanten bemalt und ich habe auch
gestern schon ihren babybauch bemalt
also da habt ihr das video
wahrscheinlich schon gesehen da war auch
ein elefant drauf also bietet sich an
murat eine dumpfe torte zu backen genau
ist sie kriegen so genau sie kriegten
sohn also wir haben ihn jetzt einfach
mal paul genannt ich weiß nicht ob sie
ihn später jedenfalls habe ich hier eine
3d dumbo torte als ich wollte schon
immer mal eine dort heute machen
und jetzt wird's eine 3d torte man muss
dazu sagen es ist keine einfache trotte
also ich saß da wirklich jetzt
zweieinhalb tage an der torte mit filmen
man muss sich da auch wirklich zeit
nehmen und ich finde man hätte sich auch
ein bisschen mehr noch zeit nehmen
müssen wenn jemand zum beispiel das
problem dass die ohren jetzt noch nicht
so ganz durchgetrocknet waren und
deswegen ein bisschen eingerissen sind
nämlich schade ist aber kann ja auch
dumm bus stehend machen aber man muss
halt die zeit haben zum durch trocknen
lassen und das hatte ich leider nicht
und daher und das war jetzt auch schnell
gemacht genau das war eigentlich echt
relativ schnell und zügig und ja alles
kann man essen das heißt man kann sowohl
die tafel essen als auch den rüssel die
mütze alles ist essbar
im inneren steckt eine heller kuchen mit
blauem zucker streuseln einer dunklen
garage und etwas marmelade und unter der
mütze und im rüssel und dem kopf steckt
zum beispiel reis christi masse man kann
alles auch aus kuchen machen aber reis
christi mit marshmallow zusammen das ist
so eine richtig tolle formbare masse
man kann dann eben zum beispiel diesem
rüssel machen ohne ihnen noch besonders
viel stabilität zu haben
genau ohne draht daneben auch und jetzt
fangen wir einfach an ich zeige euch
womit ich zuerst gestartet
wird das war nämlich die reis christi
masse und dafür zeige ich euch mal die
zutaten für die reis christi masse
brauche ich 700 gramm marshmallows 700
gramm reis christie's das netz die
schoko christie's und 70 gramm butter
und für die hände ein bisschen back
trance prey
zuerst nimmt jetzt die marshmallows und
die gebe ich jetzt bei mir in einer
pfanne und wertz weit geringer hitze
schmelzen lassen
schneller geht es ganze in einer
mikrowelle falls ihr also eine habt
könnt ihr bei geringerer wattzahl die
marshmallows schmelzen lassen und
zwischendurch immer mal wieder rühren
damit ich die marshmallows sehr gut
verrühren kann gebe ich jetzt noch die
butter mit dazu und für sie so lange um
bis geschmolzen ist zum schluss verbinde
ich jetzt noch die flüssige marshmallow
mache mit den reis christie's am anfang
ganz kurz mit dem löffel bis die
marshmallows ein bisschen abgekühlt sind
und dann nehme ich einfach die hände und
fette währenddessen meine hände immer
mal wieder mit buck trend spray damit
die masse nicht so sehr klebt und zum
säubern der pfanne gibt hier einfach ein
bisschen wasser in die pfanne lasst das
ganze aufkochen und dann bekommt ihr die
marshmallows ihr ganz einfach wieder
heraus habe ich die macht sich gut
zusammen geknetet und jetzt wird daraus
der kopf geformt dafür habe ich jetzt
schon mal ein großes stück genommen und
ihm ist es wirklich immer schön kompakt
zusammendrücken und ich schaue einfach
immer mal wieder auf meinen laptop da
habe ich nämlich die vorlage von domburg
und der kopf ist so dass er ziemlich
quadratisch auch aussieht aber ein
bisschen abgerundet hinten
das heißt ähnlich wie bei der boss baby
torte und das ganze wird ja später noch
mit modelle schokolade modelliert und
auch platt gemacht von daher ist es
jetzt erst mal nur die grundstruktur und
die hände könnt ihr zwischendurch immer
wieder mit buck transport hätten
denn so bleibt die masse nicht an ihren
händen kleben
[Musik]
die kopfform habe ich jetzt in etwa und
ich habe ich jetzt noch den rüssel
geformt und dann müsst ihr einfach drauf
achten dass es schön proportional dazu
passt das heißt er ist jetzt auch nicht
so lang das ist ja baby dumbo und jetzt
habe ich hier noch mal ein paar
marshmallows einfach erhitzt und nehmen
einen schaschlikspieß damit ich das
ganze später auch am kopf befestigen
kann
und die marshmallow masse die dient
jetzt sozusagen als kleber und das
stecke ich jetzt hier rein und wenn ich
später dann den rüssel befestigen will
habe ich so einfach keine probleme jetzt
werde ich die einzelnen teile weil sie
jetzt einfach beim abkühlen bisschen
auseinander gehen in frischhaltefolie
packen so dass sie wirklich schön
kompakt zusammen bleiben und so lasse
ich sie dann einfach über einen tag
trocknen ihr könnt ihr noch zwei tage
stehen lassen da passiert nichts und
dann geht es mit der torte wieder weiter
[Musik]
für den teig brauche ich drei eier eine
prise salz etwas vanille extrakt 150
gramm zucker 150 milliliter
sonnenblumenöl und buttermilch 225 gramm
mehl eineinhalb teelöffel backpulver
diesmal getötet
100 g mandeln die habe ich bereits fein
gemahlen und wer möchte kann noch ein
paar bunte streifen zufügen und ich
werde noch den abruf von einer
unbehandelten zitrone zufügen
aus den zutaten mit jetzt ein rohr öl
teig zubereitet das heißt ich nehme
jetzt zuerst einmal die eier geht sie in
die rührschüssel jetzt werden die eier
mit dem salz dem vanille extrakt und dem
zucker für etwa vier bis fünf minuten
cremig verrührt sobald die eier zucker
masse dann cremig ist kommt jetzt noch
die zitronenschale mieter zogen
gemeinsam mit dem sonnenblumenöl und der
buttermilch jetzt kann ich noch die
trockenen zutaten also mehl backpulver
und mandeln verrühren und die ganz kurz
unterrühren
[Musik]
und zum schluss werden jetzt noch die
bunten streuseln ein gerät
[Musik]
jetzt fühle ich den teig in meine
backform die habe ich bereits auf 22 cm
durchmesser eingestellt und die gleiche
portion teig werde ich jetzt noch einmal
zu bereiten und dann name 18 vom backen
und dann kann ich später aus beiden
teilen den körper zusammensetzen
beim backen hilft übrigens wenn man den
teil so ein bisschen am rand hochsteigt
und es ist übrigens völlig normal dass
unten ein kleiner rand ausläuft deckt
eick kommt jetzt in den vorgeheizten
backofen bei 170 grad ober unterhitze da
brauche etwa 30 bis 35 minuten die
kleinere portion also der kleinere
durchmesser braucht ein paar minuten
länger
die kuchen würden die sind jetzt bereits
abgekühlt und ich habe auch in der
zwischenzeit eine garage gestellt aus
zarter schokolade da findet ihr das
rezept auf meinem blog und die habe ich
jetzt auch bereits abkühlen lassen
jetzt kann ich die tortenböden mit einer
torten säge durchschneiden und sie dann
füllen
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier ein skateboard zum
befüllen der torte das bis 30 jetzt ein
bisschen mit der garage damit die torte
einfach gut drauf kleben kann
und jetzt werde ich und es ist
eigentlich so die leistung dieterle
bringen ist als hat mir so eine
schablone ausgedruckt jetzt muss ich
hier praktisch die torte stapeln die
kuchen böden der größere der hat ja 220
cm im durchmesser und von der größe her
passt es auch ganz gut das heißt jetzt
kommt zuerst der boden und ich werde
jetzt einfach die torte komplett so
stapeln und später dann in form
schneiden das heißt hier werden auch die
beine weg geschnitten und so weiter und
man muss halt immer wieder den kopf
nehmen und dran halten und der kopf ist
so das größte bei baby turbo aber der
körper darf natürlich auch nicht zu
klein sein
jetzt habe ich hier ein bisschen
aprikosenmarmelade bereits erwärmt und
die streiche ich jetzt auf den boden
drauf und befülle die torte dann
komplett mit ghanas ihr könnt hier im
prinzip auch eine buttercreme gerne
nehmen also eine sonder tauglich aber
bei so 3d torten arbeite ich lieber
gerne mit einer garage weil die einfach
ein bisschen fester wird und dann die
torte unten eben schön stabil wird
[Musik]
jetzt kommt die letzte schicht und jetzt
steht schon mal das grundgerüst für
dumbo und ich kann jetzt in kuchen für
etwa eine stunde in den kühlschrank
stellen
dadurch sieht ja nach schönefeld und
dann kann ich den kuchen in form
schneiden jetzt schneide ich sind körper
zurecht und dafür nehme ich jetzt immer
mal wieder den kopf und setzte ihn drauf
das heißt ich muss jetzt hier vorne ein
bisschen was wegschneiden damit der
bauch einfach ein bisschen nicht ganz so
breit ist und alle reste die ich habe
war ich noch auf denn die brauche ich
noch für die arme und für die beine
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich schon mal die grobe form
und wie gesagt nämlich immer mal wieder
den kopf der kopf kommt jetzt ungefähr
so hin also da guckt ein bisschen nach
oben
da kommt ja dann auch der rüssel so
tragen das heißt der russin schaut auch
mittel nach oben
und da ich das später noch eine tafel
hin machen möchte habe jetzt einfach mal
so ein blatt papier genommen und
hingehalten dass ich ungefähr weiß wie
groß das die tafel sein kann
und jetzt nehme ich die übrigen
kuchenstücke und die füße und werdet ihr
jetzt dran halten
und jetzt praktisch diese zwischenräume
hier ausfüllen und mit ghana schon immer
wieder ein streichen um die füße zu
formen
[Musik]
so sieht die torte jetzt aus jetzt geht
es weiter mit dem zusammenbau dafür habe
ich jetzt hier eine kleine platte
ausgeschnitten ihr könnt jetzt da zum
beispiel in der körper platte nehmen
also eine live platte oder auch einen
cache bord und das einfach und zu
schneiden
das werde jetzt hier drauf gleich
platziert und darunter müssen jetzt
dübel gesteckt werden damit das gewicht
vom kopf einfach nicht ein senkt und
dafür habe ich jetzt hier einfach so
kunststoff hora aus dem baumarkt besorgt
und jetzt werde ich da etwa vier stücke
reinstecken
ihr müsst die halt dann vor dem verzehr
einfach entfernen und vorher gut sauber
machen
[Musik]
und ist jetzt schon ich kann da jetzt
richtig drauf drücken ohne dass ich die
torte flach drücken
und da gebe ich jetzt noch mal ein
bisschen kanalstr über das heißt die
platte wird jetzt auch schön verdeckt
und wie gesagt da müsste dann einfach
vor dem verzehr drauf achten und darauf
hinweisen dass da eben nicht es waren
platte drunter steckt
[Musik]
und jetzt habe ich hier noch ein
rundholz mit einem zentimeter
durchmesser auch vom baumarkt und das
habe ich jetzt bereits so zugeschnitten
dass er einmal durch den körper geht und
dann eben auch durch den kopf das heißt
somit wird der kopf am körper befestigt
oder mich dir jetzt hier rein kriege
muss ich da vorne einfach kurz spitzen
jetzt kann ich die spitze verwenden um
vielleicht schon platte durch zu bauen
könnte aber auch gerne einmal mit dem
messer vorher kennzeichnet dann
andersherum rein und jetzt kann ich den
kopf erstmal auf spießen um einfach zu
schauen ob die proportionen stimmen und
später nehme ich ihnen aber noch mal
kurz weg
[Musik]
so gefällt mir ganz gut aber damit ich
einfache arbeiten kann nehme ich jetzt
den kopf herunter und den steig jetzt
einfach etwas styropor stelle in zur
seite und kann jetzt erstmal mit der
unterseite weiterarbeiten
jetzt werden die arme befestigt und da
muss ich immer daran denken dass hier
noch die tafel drankommt und jetzt nehme
ich schon mal den die hand sozusagen und
steckt die ich hier rein mit einem
schaschlikspieß
[Musik]
und jetzt fühle ich das zwischenstück
hier sowie auf der seite mit kuchen aus
und stellt den kuchen jetzt aber immer
mal wieder zwischendurch kühl damit
einfach die erste schicht fest werden
kann
und dann kann ich wieder daran
weiterarbeiten
[Musik]
also das ist jetzt eine ziemlich lustige
konstruktion
ich werde jetzt mit dem kopf hier
weitermachen und damit ich an dem kopf
arbeiten kann könnt ihr entweder einen
styropor blog nehmen und das ganze rein
stecken
ich habe jetzt keinen meter also nehme
ich mein lochblech den da passt das
starb ganz gut durch und da kann ich am
kopf arbeiten
ich habe ich jetzt modell ihr schokolade
und mit der also die kann ich immer
wieder weich kneten und mit der kann ich
jetzt zum beispiel hier die wangen noch
schön formen so ein bisschen
gesichtszüge reinbringen oder hier hin
da fehlt einfach noch ein kleines stück
wo ich bisschen zu wenig von dem reis
crispy massa hatte und das kann ich
jetzt hier so dran drücken und mit den
fingern zu recht formen
[Musik]
weiter geht's mit dem bus kopf also
momentan sieht es so aus
meine version ist ein bisschen größer
als die vorlage und habe ich jetzt
einfach mal ein auge ausgeschnitten und
ich werde jetzt einfach schauen wo das
auge hin muss ungefähr auf die höhe
da lege ich es einmal drauf und kann
jetzt ein messer nehmen und bisschen
größer drumherum schneiden und das ganze
ausfüllen und dann nehme ich einfach
noch ein bisschen von der restlichen
garage und streiche den kopf so glatt
dass er neben gut gefällt
[Musik]
ich habe nochmal eine reif christi masse
gemacht um dem bus hände und füße zu
formen dieses mal habe ich die
marshmallows in der mikrowelle
geschmolzen und es funktioniert auch
viel viel besser und vor allem geht es
viel schneller für die hände und die
füße habe ich jetzt kleine kuppelartige
figuren hergestellt und die habe ich
jetzt aushärten lassen und den rest habe
ich einfach in den eckigen back rahmen
eingefüllt und schön flach gedrückt das
heißt mit einem aus hall starb darüber
gerollt und hat es auch aushalten lassen
und aus dem rechteck wird jetzt eine
tafel gemacht
[Musik]
für die tafel habe ich jetzt hier eine
vorlage gemacht aus papier damit ich
einfach ungefähr weiß wie groß sein darf
und jetzt kann ich das einfach zurecht
schneiden damit die tafel auch schon
fest wird streiche ich sie jetzt
komplett mit der garage ein und stellt
sie dann in den kühlschrank
ihr könnt die tafel im prinzip auch aus
blüten passte machen komplett aus blüten
passte dann wird es wirklich steinhart
und man könnte es ja auch für immer
aufheben
so muss man sich natürlich auf essen
denn die garage ist nicht haltbar
hab jetzt schon fest geworden und die
ränder die habe ich einfach nochmal
weggeschnitten mit der schablone
natürlich und jetzt habe ich hier
schwarzen und grünen von dann vermischt
und bis in 10 c 1 geknetet und das ganze
rolle ich jetzt auch bäcker stärke auf
etwa 3 mm stärke aus
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich die platte und jetzt
nehme ich wieder meine schablone und
kann das jetzt einmal ausschneiden und
das ist dann die tafel die trocknen
lassen und dann beschritten werde
[Musik]
und den rest könnte ich jetzt wieder
zusammen rollen zu einer platte aus und
deckt dann die tafel einmal komplett
damit ein
[Musik]
jetzt streicht sich die frontplatte mit
etwas kleber ein und legt dann die tafel
mit ich drauf und jetzt kann ich die
beiden seitenteile einschlagen und so
abschneiden dass sie sich hinten
berühren
jetzt kann ich nach oben und unten die
überreste mit der tankkarte wegnehmen
das habe ich jetzt so weit vorbereitet
da fehlen mir ist nur noch die hölzer am
rand die werde ich jetzt noch schnell
vorbereiten
für den holzrahmen habe ich jetzt für
den pastor genommen die trocknet nämlich
sehr schnell durch
und da habe ich einfach ein bisschen
brauereien gemischt und das ganze schön
marmoriert und jetzt kann ich es auch 5
mm stärke ausrollen und jetzt nämlich
modell ihr werkzeug ihr könnt aber auch
zum beispiel einen zahnstocher nehmen
oder mit gabel und löffel messer und
könnte hier einfach so kleine holz
strukturen reinmachen
[Musik]
jetzt müssen sich noch die tafel
ausmessen also einmal die länge und
natürlich dann auch die breite und kann
jetzt einfach die vier holzlatten
ausschneiden hier drauflegen und
trocknen lassen
als nächstes mache ich jetzt die tafel
fertigt die elemente sind jetzt alle
schön durchgetrocknet und ich habe jetzt
hier diese tafel front und wörthsee mit
weißer farbe bemalen die prüfer farbe
könnt ihr zum beispiel mit alkohol
wasser oder auch ein bisschen verrühren
und dann male ich habe mir hier eine
vorlage gemacht und auch eine in der
richtigen größe und kann dass es hier
schön drauf malen
[Musik]
und jetzt kann ich die einzelnen teile
einfach mit etwas essbarem kleber
zusammenkleben
[Musik]
die zwischenzeit muss sich jetzt um die
dekoration vorzubereiten und deshalb
jetzt dumm bus kragen da habe ich jetzt
250 km roten fondant mit etwas cnc
prüfer verknetet damit er eben gut
aushärtet und das kann ich jetzt
ausrollen auf etwa 3 mm stärke
[Musik]
und das ausrollen geht am besten auf
etwas becken stärke die cover nämlich
super zum ausrollen verwenden davon dann
klebt dann nicht und vor allem kann man
sich später ganz einfach wieder
wegwischen
[Musik]
für den kragen brauche ich jetzt eine
grundform er könnte entweder einem kreis
ausschneiden oder zum beispiel eine
blume und ich nehme jetzt einfach hier
den falz und schneide jetzt hier entlang
und wichtig ist einfach nur dass es ein
bisschen größer ist als der kopf und
dumbo
[Musik]
das kann ich kurz zur seite legen und
habe ich jetzt ein bisschen gelb das
soll ich jetzt auch dünn aus und
schneidet dann streifen zu recht
[Musik]
ein gelber streifen wird jetzt hier
drauf geklebt mit hilfe von etwas
lebensmittel kleber und ich werde mir
das einfach vorher kurz mit einem modell
werkzeug markieren und dann ganz auch
wenn sich draufkleben
[Musik]
und damit das ganze jetzt nicht so flach
darlegt nehme ich jetzt hier dieser
schilderung förmchen
ihr könnt aber zb auch alufolie einfach
zusammenstellen oder ein bisschen
küchenpapier und es einfach runter
stecken damit wir so eine schöne
struktur bekommen
[Musik]
jetzt lasse ich den kragen so einfach
durch trocknen ist ja jetzt alle reste
zusammengenäht also ein bisschen gelb
und weiß und frauen und habe hier so
eine schöne haarfarbe schön ausgerollt
und jetzt werde ich das skateboard damit
überziehen
das heißt ich bestreite das skateboard
mit etwas lebensmittels leber und legt
dann denn von dann drüber und streicheln
glatt und später mache ich noch ein
bisschen struktur rein sondern was eben
auch aussieht wie heute
[Musik]
bethesda skateboard vorbereitet und kann
noch durch trocknen
ich arbeite heute an meine torte weiter
und stelle sie jetzt fertig gestern war
es einfach ein bisschen zu spät ich habe
jetzt hier noch mit reis crispy maße
auch einen hut gemacht und damit ich
daran arbeiten kann spielt sich das hier
einfach auch so ein bisschen styropor
und bestreicht die mit sie jetzt einfach
mit der ghana
[Musik]
jetzt wird der elefant dumbo in fondant
eingeschlagen dafür habe ich jetzt drei
kilo weisen von dann weiß geknetet und
jeweils 250 gramm blau und schwarz ein
geknetet und jetzt habe ich so ein
schönes blau grau oder taubenblau könnte
man sagen und die torte war ja jetzt
über nach dem kühlschrank von daher hat
sie jetzt die perfekte konsistenz und
ich darf jetzt in front nur nicht so
dünn ausrollen also man kann den
wirklich sehr dünn ausrollen wie man
möchte
aber ich möchte gleich noch ein paar
falten reihen sehen und deswegen darf
jetzt nicht zu dünn sein also vier bis
fünf millimeter sind hier perfekt die
torte bis durch ist einmal komplett mit
back transparent damit er von dort
gleich darauf haften kann und das
bestreite ich gleich kurz mit den händen
jetzt lege ich hier die von der decke
vorsichtig drüber und muss ihn dann
einfach mit den händen schön anpassen
und die überreste wegschneiden einfach
[Musik]
jetzt ist dumpf kopf dran da wird jetzt
auch eingesprüht
den habe ich bereits glatt gestrichen
und dann wieder von der decke überzogen
und wenn ihr mal noch drin habt das ist
mir vorhin auch passiert das ist gar
nicht schlimm dass können da einfach
wieder zu flicken und so ein bisschen
verstreichen und dann sieht man es
später auch nicht
[Musik]
beim rüsselsheim und ich schneide jetzt
hier auch schon mal den rest weg einfach
damit der russe jetzt nicht nach vorne
umkippt
[Musik]
jetzt mache ich noch kleine
schatteneffekte und zwar habe ich jetzt
hier hellblau und schwarz als pulver
farbe gemischt und weil das jetzt hier
in die falken mit rein geben so bekommen
sie einfach ein bisschen mehr tiefe
[Musik]
für die augenform ich etwas weißem von
sandoval und klebe ihn dann mit essbaren
kleber in die augenhöhle die schwarze
umrandung und die wimpern könnt ihr dann
mit hilfe von von land oder
lebensmittelfarbe machen wenn die blaue
er ist nämlich blaue modelle schokolade
ein ganz kleines stück und das wird
jetzt ein bisschen oval geformt und als
auch dran gedrückt einfach mit ein
bisschen kleber
[Musik]
und die umrandung mache ich wieder mit
schwarzer metallic farben und setzte
später noch einen weißen punkt mit der
weißen farbe rein
[Musik]
zeit zum zusammensetzen ich habe das
skateboard noch ein bisschen mit pulver
eingestrichen und damit die torte jetzt
auch auf dem kickboard hier klebt
nämlich ein bisschen nach wir können zum
beispiel auch eiweiß sprits glasow
nehmen einfach etwas womit hotel ag zum
beispiel auch gucke ich einfach mal ich
denke dass ich sie ziemlich mittig
platziert
[Musik]
bisschen nach vorne denn es kommen ja
noch die motoren und die brauchen auch
platz
[Musik]
zuerst das jetzt dumbo es kranz dran
hier in der mitte haben wir ja das loch
für den stab da kommt jetzt ein bisschen
kleber drauf hier in der mitte habe ich
ein kleines loch ausgestochen
das macht ihr am besten dann wenn die
macher noch weich ist aber es klappt
auch so ganz wunderbar und ich habe es
ein bisschen mit bakterien spray einfach
eingesprüht damit den glanz bekommt
den ersten teil habe ich jetzt schon mal
fertig und ich bin ein bisschen
erleichtert
jetzt müssen wir erstmal platz im
kühlschrank schaffen denn die torte ist
ziemlich hoch
als nächstes werde ich jetzt noch die
münze nehmen und die mit von dort über
ziehen denn die muss hier auch noch oben
drauf und dann schaue ich einfach noch
etwas fehlt
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich dombauhütte anstecken
ich mache jetzt bisschen seitlich jetzt
fehlt nur noch der saum außen rum und
staffel habe ich jetzt noch mal 250
gramm gelben von dann ausgerollt da
schneide ich jetzt einen ganz breiten
streifen so ist den kleber rein
jetzt kann ich den einmal umklappen ein
ende stelle ich jetzt hier schon mal
gerade und jetzt kann ich das hier aus
den grundsätzen auch mit etwas kleber
und dann schön fixieren
[Musik]
jetzt sind die dran dafür habe ich mir
hier eine schablone gezeichnet und
ausgeschnitten und den von dann habe ich
vorher mit zehn prüfer verknetet damit
die ohren auch schön aus herten können
jetzt kann ich das einfach mit hilfe der
schablone ausschneiden
[Musik]
dion längst kurz zur seite und hier habe
ich noch ein stück rosa mit bisschen
gelb und weiß verknetet 18.10 pulver
untergemischt
und das werde ich jetzt aber ganz dünn
ausrollen und bisschen kleiner
ausschneiden und hier drüber kleben
[Musik]
und jetzt soll ich mit dem ausland starb
einfach nochmal über die ohren damit
sich blau und rosa schön verbinden und
damit fast eine ebene gibt
[Musik]
die ohren sind natürlich auch irgendwie
befestigt werden ich habe jetzt ein
bisschen kleber auf die beiden teile
drauf gestrichen und die ohren jetzt
daran geklebt damit sie natürlich so ein
bisschen ab stehen und nicht einfach nur
herunter hängen muss man sie ein
bisschen fixieren und auch ein bisschen
stabilisieren ich habe jetzt einfach
styropor zusammengesteckt und runter
gestellt habe ich auch ein bisschen
küchenpapier
und so muss ich einfach die ohren jetzt
trocknen lassen am besten über nacht und
dann kann ich die styroporteile
wegnehmen und hoffe einfach dass sie gut
halten
also das ist auch für mich muss ich
sagen eine herausforderung die
alternative wäre gewesen die eurem
vorzubereiten und dann wirklich trocknen
zu lassen und dann dran zu kleben aber
dann kriegt man sich hinten eventuell
nicht ganz bündig an die torte geklebt
von daher habe ich das jetzt so gemacht
jetzt fehlt noch der schwanz hinten der
muss natürlich auch daran dafür habe ich
jetzt hier so ein kleines stück bereits
ausgerollt auch mit cmc pulver und jetzt
mache ich kleine härchen und die werden
dann wie ein pinsel außenrum geklebt
[Musik]
so sieht jetzt also dumm wo aus sie
werden ihn jetzt gleich transportieren
zum glück findet die babyparty nur zwei
straßen weiter statt das heißt ich werde
den offenen schoß nehmen im auto ich
würde auch hin laufen aber das bis hin
zu schwer
und dann kann man ihn dorthin bringen
ich werde ihnen jetzt auch als ich hatte
ihn es über nacht im kühlschrank und
jetzt werde ich ihnen einfach bei
raumtemperatur lagern da dürft jetzt
auch nichts mehr passieren die ohren ja
mein gott jetzt ist sogar aber es ist ja
nicht schlimm aber zeit geschuldet
so hat ja auch ab und zu so einem
pferdeschwanz also senioren so
zusammengebunden natürlich auch von seh
ich glaube ich weiß wie die kids kennen
ist doch gar nicht also wir lesen auch
gerne mit samira und ella und das ist so
ein kleiner elefant und die frau zum
boot ist die mama von dumbo ja die
erarbeiteten zirkus und dann kommt da
storch und alle anderen tiere bekommen
ihre babys als ihre päckchen nur
forschung honig und dann ist schon ganz
traurig und irgendwann kommt dann doch
der stolz am nächsten morgen und dann
bringt der frau zum wurdest eckchen und
da ist eben dumbo drin
und der hatte als seine und so nach
hinten geklappt und dann muss auch
plötzlich niesen und dann klappen sich
seine riesigen ohren auf und die ganzen
anderen elefanten die lachen dann dumbo
auswahl us-riesen ohren hat und da wird
dann auch von den ganzen kindern und so
weiter immer ausgelacht und das ist echt
eigentlich ein ganz trauriger seine
klasse auch ein ohr habe ihn gehänselt
ja und dann ist es aber so dass dumbo
dann fliegen lernt mit seinen ohren
dh das was vorher sein nachteil war hat
er dann zu seinem vorteil genutzt und
das war eben dann keine schwäche sondern
eine stärke das war unser team baden
abstellen und habe nicht immer dumm und
glaubt der posaunist heubachs geworden
ja es ist immer was ja das wollte pilot
ja und das ist eine richtig richtig
süßes gesicht auch leute zu hause mit
abständen und lustig das ist auch nicht
das ist auch nicht lieb wenn das kinder
untereinander
machen für kinder - oft gar nichts naja
jedenfalls war das in kürze vor dem bus
geschichte und ich hoffe die lisa freut
sich jetzt gleich über die torte im
anschluss lädt jetzt noch ein paar
bilder von der babyparty und wer das
video gestern nicht gesehen habt schaut
auf jeden fall mal rein
das rezept geht es zum nachlesen auf
salehs blog.de falls ihr die torte nach
macht was glaubt man macht die torten
doch bist du die maßnahmen bestimmt
jemand glaubt gar nicht wie viele leute
das nun ach ja und noch mal ganz neu auf
die cebit orte haben fehler nach kann
man meist und es ganz will ich noch zu
sagen ist dem motiv dort ist nur dann
ein motiv trotte wählen sie auch
schmeckt der ganz ganz wichtig und das
ist schon gespannt drauf wobei die
kuchen reste die habe ich alle schon
aufgegessen die waren super lecker und
super saftig der nickt er hat nämlich
auch probiert also wir gehen zu unserer
party bevor die verpassen und wir sehen
uns beim nächsten mal wieder biss dann
tschüss schnell bei uns kommt dumbo und
dumm wo du kannst dir fliegen
er fliegt schon mal voraus
[Musik]